I guess you start off with the audience
went crazy especially during one scene
that's the Licking scene like wait what
is that like Megan like how do you even
prepare for that what is you know so in
that scene we kind of just like really
really went for it and I remember in one
take we were doing that scene and it's
like me and Dennis and he says like kind
of moused me he's like spit on me and
I'm like and I so I keep and you know
I'm keep acting up a scene and he goes
spit on me and I'm like wait what's
happening right now and then I hear
Dennis I mean I hear Dianna in the other
room behind the UM TV and he's like spit
on him
and I'm like so I'm like sitting in the
chair and I'm like he was like no get a
good when it's uh you know I got a good
one and you know we got it in and but it
was fun because he's just willing to go
anywhere and I think that in a way that
makes us bolder where we're just like
let's just try it you never know what's
gonna happen I think that's when magic
kind of does happen because you just go
for it and see you know what could
happen yes how much does your
performance change based on what Dennis
brings because he goes crazy I think as
an actor your job is to react yeah yeah
I think dennis really kind of drives
this movie as the title character and
the villain yeah I think he really
drives this movie because we're forced
to almost react yeah to him because he
won't go away I mean how much does your
performance change in the moment based
like are there specific examples where
you come in with one set of ideas and
then based on what he's doing you change
up yeah I think actors like we had to
see like there's an argument scene that
we had and every time we did it it
changed because if it you know if he
came one way that I reacted a different
way so then the next time it comes
around it's like well now I'm getting
more aggressive and so he's like oh and
I'm gonna take a totally different
approach and bring you down to here make
you feel crazy when you start to play
jazz
I start to kind of just listen and react
and that's actually where it gets more
to be more fun yeah house starring in
this movie affected how you view your
own house and your own security yes when
we were filming his movie
I was in the middle of a home renovation
only my wife wanted a panic room and I
was like maybe we need a panic route I
just made a route out of the house so
that you can definitely get the kids you
know what I mean in case you know I'm
not there or something so yeah it's uh
it's it will alter a lot you know I
think it'll alter help people view
buying a house I think you know I'll do
help people view living in their current
home for sure for sure thank you both so
much
absolutely